good morning john if your life is
anything like mine there's going to be a
time
in it when you decide to do a thing and
at first
you love the thing it's an amazing thing
the greatness of the thing is
so inspiring it fills your tank so much
that you hit the ground running and you
sprint
for weeks maybe months and during that
time you never even question its
greatness but then
maybe a couple of the things that made
the idea so great
feel a little less great now maybe some
of the
initial fuel that was fueling you runs
out maybe the world changes
in totally unnecessary and ridiculously
annoying ways
that make you feel less enthusiastic
about it then you have to decide maybe
even once you're like three quarters of
the way through the project
if you want to keep going like you're
still doing it the default state
is to just keep doing it and so it's
hard to stop but it seems at this point
a little onerous like you're not
that excited about it anymore maybe
you'll say okay let's just
let's just stop or maybe you'll say i
don't care if this isn't fun anymore
i decided to do this thing and i'm ding
dong gonna do it and that's not like
good that's not stick-to-itiveness
that's not perseverance it's
stubbornness it's simply saying like
world
i don't care if you don't want me to do
this i don't care if nobody likes it i
don't care
if it's not a good idea anymore i said i
was gonna do this thing and you can
burn down around me but i'm going to
keep
hiking up this hill even though it's hot
even though i don't like it even though
i'm not sure
why i started in the first place or what
i'm gonna see when i get up there
then even when you're being driven by
pure stubbornness
and not any kind of relentless fortitude
not
the hustle that everyone says you need
these days
but just because you said you were gonna
do it then maybe
you find something you find something
new something interesting something
inspiring you learn something about
yourself even if you should have given
up
long ago you find some insight or the
world changes again
and the idea becomes good and then
you'll be like see
i did it i was relentless i stuck with
it and it was worth it i knew it even
though everyone told me to quit except
it wasn't your genius
it wasn't your relentlessness it was
just that you were stubborn
and you got lucky because it's just as
likely maybe even more so
that this sprint that you started out on
but the world has been screaming at you
saying day after day week after week
isn't really working is only going to
get more sticky and laborious as time
goes on and then the people who are
watching you publicly subject yourself
to this foolhardy task will shake their
heads and say
what are they doing what are they doing
and the only response that you have
the only honest response anyway is i
said i was gonna do it
i started doing the thing and i can't
stop and once i have done it
at least i will have done it and that
will be something
it'll be something what's the right
thing to do in a situation like that
don't come to me because my answer is do
it
just do it i just keep going until
you're done as long as there is an end
date as long as it's in sight
keep going even if it makes no sense
even if you don't really like it anymore
you never
know what you're gonna learn out there
you never know what you're gonna see
and at the end at least you will have
done it anyway john this is just
something i've been thinking about not
really applicable to anything in my life
right now
but certainly something i've been
through before maybe it'll be helpful to
you or somebody else watching
good news the second episode of bizarre
beasts if you're missing that here on
vlogbrothers is up
on the youtube.com bizarrebeast's
youtube channel it's hosted by sarah
suda and it's about the watson which is
one of my favorite birds also oran's
favorite youtube show scishow kids is
coming back
you can find it now at youtube.com
slideshowkids with hundreds of episodes
we've already uploaded but new ones will
start
going live on monday and finally james
from journey to the micro cosmos just
got a new microscope and it's so
beautiful
made me cry john i'll see you on tuesday